okay i have another question for them
i'm genuinely curious
uh let's say if you
end up very unhappy or maybe you're just
like
something can just switch you know maybe
you can just like oh i don't like him
anymore would you hurt me
would you stay married
to him for the rest of your life you're
not sexually attracted you don't like
he's just not funny anymore you just
don't like him do we do we have kids
yeah if we have kids it's not about me
anymore
so you would rather see your children
grow up in a home where parents are
sleeping in separate bedrooms they don't
talk they don't hold hair they don't
kiss i would rather see my kids grow up
at home where they're at every
statistical advantage rather than
statistical disadvantage because if the
father is out of the home that you put
that kid at risk
why
because life is not easy like it's you
you might think you know as a woman like
oh my kid's gonna be fine your child is
just another human being in this world
the world is gonna show your kids that
they're at a disadvantage because that
was that was the question i had i
actually i used to hate all my friends
when i was a kid that had two parent
households right and i would look at
them like why why are they so happy and
now that i'm older i can reflect i'm
like man everything that they say about
being in a single mother home it just
isn't a good time we were talking about
it because we were talking about mental
health the other day and i was saying
like mental health isn't a thing in my
family like we're all just happy people
and she she says to me that's because
you had both parents in the home
i don't agree with that because there's
a lot of people who have mental health
issues but science doesn't care about
your feelings it's true you are at a
disadvantage it's very negative outcomes
i mean we can continue to facilitate
this and then cry about the dating
market but like women are kind of
constructing these problems like we're
raising these children in broken homes
because we're choosing to reproduce with
men who aren't our first choice
so you would stay in a marriage you
don't love somebody anymore
what is love what is it you love your
husband yes i love my husband so then if
you like let's say what like some okay
let me just finish my sentence before
you jump in
things can happen
you can separate with someone you can be
with him for 20 years and then you're
like i don't want to be here anymore
okay maybe not 20. let's say 10 years
because we're still talking about kids
so you would want to show your kids
that you like it's okay to live in a
marriage in a loveless marriage well so
here here's the thing
you leave him right so what's the what's
the idea my mom is a happy joyful
divorcee and my parents are split do you
not know what co-parenting is i
understand co-parenting but you're also
acting like most women are willing to
co-parent in an agreeable manner that's
not what i've seen yeah
people who get a divorce obviously
sometimes there's a lot of drama right
but sometimes people can co-parent you
don't agree with that that's no one's
first choice though
what's no one
co-parenting is not anyone's first
choice it's something that you're forced
to do because you made poor decisions
either with choosing the man or choosing
to end it and most of the time women are
the ones leaving if they're saying
they're unhappy and sometimes i don't
believe like the reasons that they're
saying that they're unhappy they think
they can go out there and they can do
better and they can't and who pays for
it the kids the kids and that's the
thing like i think if you leave just
based on happiness you're selfish
because you're putting you're putting
your own hat no because you're putting
your own happiness above the kid's
happiness that's something your kids are
not happy if their mom is not happy i'm
sorry
ellie you were in a single mother home
would you have preferred both parents in
the home or did you prefer having your
mom happy
i i would have preferred well some women
you just can't make happy but i would
say having a two-parent household i
think about that sometimes like what
what would it have been like i have no
point of reference for a two-parent
household you know all i can do is look
around at my friends that i was like
resentful that they were so happy i mean
you can you can think what you want and
women are going to keep doing it they're
going to keep leaving men because they
don't feel happy and they're going to
take half of his stuff like it's
different if you leave amicably and you
don't try to rob him which it is robbery
you can call it child support you call
out money it can still be unethical if
you mate with an involved father there's
no reason to take him to court so it's
like you know yeah leave if you're not
happy and take half his stuff that's not
a message i can get behind like figure
it out go to couples counseling you're
you're an autonomous intelligent woman
what do you need to go out and you need
to do the work quick question for you
guys because we gotta wrap up by six
here um did you sign a prenup when you
got married oh no i was supposed to but
then things popped off in ukraine
so no prenup no so your man is
technically at risk i'm sure he's yeah
but with your attitude he ain't going
nowhere believe me
would you sign a prenup if you're a guy
yeah okay
would you sign a prenup you would yeah
well look at us all getting along here